à la veille du nouvel an des personnes
se pressent pour avoir le résultat après
cette fête testé sur le nouveau site de
dépistage rapide de l'aéroport
international de los angeles
des millions d'américains se sont
déplacés pour les fêtes de fin d'année
malgré les nombreux appels des autorités
à rester chez soi sur le week-end du 26
décembre l'agent chargé des contrôles de
sécurité dans les aéroports a même
recensé un record du nombre de passagers
depuis la mi mars le nombre de personnes
positives au kovy 19 a de son côté
explosé avec un million de cas recensés
en moins d'une semaine à travers le pays
ces derniers jours
le variant britannique du virus a été
identifié dans plusieurs états de
l'ouest américain
mais le célèbre immunologue anthony
fauci assure ne pas être surpris ni
particulièrement inquiet et bien tout
d'abord je ne suis pas surpris qu'il y
ait un cas et probablement même plus en
californie et nous allons probablement
d'abord dans notre état je pense que
cela va arriver parce que si vous avez
beaucoup de cas au royaume uni avec tous
les voyages non seulement directement
vers les états unis mais aussi à travers
d'autres pays par intermittence comme à
l'est du royaume uni à la france puis de
la france aux états unis et cetera donc
je ne pense pas que les californiens
devrait sentir que c'est quelque chose
d'étrange c'est quelque chose qui est
attendu les américains s'accroche malgré
tout à l'espoir d'une immunisation
rapide de la population avec le
lancement le 14 décembre dernier de la
plus grande campagne de vaccination de
l'histoire des états unis
depuis ce selon les chiffres du centre
de contrôle et de prévention des
maladies
environ 3 millions de personnes ont déjà
reçu la première dose de l'an vaccin
très loin de l'objectif des 20 millions
de personnes vaccinées avant 2021 promis
par l'administration tron un retard
critiquée par le président élu joe biden
mais imputer la lenteur de certains
états par donald trump
certains et attardo goku à vacciner
malgré une distribution de vaccins
réussi et à très grande échelle par le
gouvernement fédéral ils le feront
l'effort de distribution et
d'administration du vaccin ne progresse
pas comme il le devrait
il ya quelques semaines l'administration
trump a suggéré que 20 millions
d'américains pourraient être vaccinées
d'ici la fin décembre
ici le programme de vaccination continue
d'avancer à ce rythme là il faudra des
années et non des mois pour vacciner
tous les américains joe biden a par
ailleurs demandé à donald trump de se
faire inoculer le vaccin pour montrer
l'exemple
selon un récent sondage 64% des
américains envisagent de se faire
vacciner
[Musique]
oh